open the sky it's a bird it's a plane
it's a movie losing sight of what its
message should have been so this is
gonna be an interesting one when it
comes to my good movie bad endings
because if I'm gonna be completely
honest this probably the most unfair one
I'm gonna do because well first of all I
don't know how many people actually I
don't know I honestly have no sense of
what the current cultural footprint of
this movie actually is that I'm gonna be
talking about I do sky high you know you
know from the title like I'd structure
is one of those things that could
potentially have like been since played
in such perpetuity on certain channels
for certain demographics that it could
have like retro actively picked up a bit
of a following like the way something
like say hocus pocus did for my
generation more or less so I could see
it being that but I don't know if it
actually is so I'm either about to talk
about a movie that nobody cares about or
that a fair amount of people do care
about but it's something that they care
about because they have a nostalgic love
for it which makes it again as I said
kind of an unfair target but I'm gonna
talk about it anyway so sky-high Matt
first of all when I saw this I was not
the target audience for it but you know
I I never really stopped I've never
considered the target age range of a
movie to be a determining factor in
whether or not I wanted to see it I want
to see movies based on do I like the
idea do I like the trailers do I think
that I'm going to enjoy this and if I
think I'm going to enjoy something that
is you know aimed at 12 year olds screw
it I'm gonna go watch something that's
aimed at 12 year olds I'm gonna like
what I like and this one even at the
time I felt a little bit cheated like it
it had the building blocks of something
a lot better and for a while I thought
yeah you know I was just the wrong age
to watch it but having gone back and
like before doing this giving it
a closer second assessment no it fails
on its own terms the ending especially
so in case this is a movie that nobody
watched and nobody knows let me to
explain
skyhigh takes the pretty fun and awesome
premise of a high school for people with
superpowers I mean before you start
going like oh it's it's like the x-men
well not quite because the whole thing
with the x-men is you know they need to
learn to control their powers and they
will ultimately make a decision do they
you know want to sort of join the fight
literally with the x-men or are they
just trying to live their lives here in
with sky high the high school is
actually trying to train them to be
superheroes so all of the normal
superhero all the normal some high
school classes are geared with that in
mind so phys ed is all about you know
dodging fireballs and stuff like that
and science class is about building ray
guns and things of that nature and it's
so it's a pretty cool idea it's it's a
nifty costume it's got a good cast
especially with the adults they they
really stacked this cast and the kids I
don't think any of them went on to
anything of note oh not true because
Leila who's kind of the best friend of
the main character that's the actress
who plays Felicity Smoak on flash so
she's doing okay but most of the other
kid actors like this movie is the
biggest thing on their acting resume
whether they've continued working or not
so but you know they're all fine they've
all gotten they've got decent chemistry
they get the job done like I said the
adult cast is kind of stacked you've got
Kurt Russell and you've got Bruce
Campbell you've got Kelly Preston yes
it's it's a really they gave these kids
a real solid backup with the adult
actors so that's all really good and the
plot is that the main character is the
son of the two most powerful best known
superheroes in the world and so there is
obviously really high expectations for
what he will do the problem is he
doesn't have any powers like any at all
and
it's compounded by the fact that he's
been hiding that from his parents he has
not going out of his way to necessarily
fake being strong but he's been DeLeo
doing little things here and there sort
of he go he's doubt come in the room and
he's pretending he's ending a rep of
weights and whatnot but he actually has
basically no powers which puts him
immediately in the out roof because one
of the things that happens at that
school is that kids get effectively
sorted into heroes and sidekicks and
that is a determination done primarily
by the phys ed teacher played by Bruce
Campbell match and that is based largely
off their powers which means that
sidekicks all have goofy powers like one
guy can turn into a puddle one guy glows
in the dark
not like like mega bright blinding just
kind of like close in the dark there's
also the main hero's best friend who I
mentioned who actually has a very cool
power of controlling plants but she
refuses to use it in a combat situation
so she gets kicked down to sidekick and
then we'll once it becomes clear cuz he
can't you know he's being tested he
can't hide the fact that he can't do
anything he can't fly it like his mom
and he's not super strong like his dad
he gets bumped down the sidekick too and
of course then you know you have what
you would expect out of this sort of
setup and for the target demographic it
has which is that a supervillain emerges
the adults aren't able to deal with it
and now this group of you know sidekicks
and people with with really weird and
kind of useless powers have to see what
they can do to make this work against
people would like some of the
legitimately great superpowers like
hurling fireballs SuperSpeed you know
sort of the elasticity thing stuff like
that in addition to some other something
you don't see as often like there's a
the main villain kind of has an
interesting quirk in terms of their
ability to manipulate and master
technology which is kind of Nate neat I
think I like I forget what they call it
in the film now but it's like a
Technomancer kind of thing so all that's
solid all of that is solid but what is
the natch
conclusion the natural lesson that a
story like this is built to tell well
it's things like you are not defined by
what your parents are capable of you
should not be beholden to the
expectations that they or people who
knew them are gonna put on you because
that's a big part of what's going on
with this main character you don't need
superpowers to be a hero to be a good
person to be heroic you don't need those
things you can still do amazing things
even if you don't have the quote-unquote
special skills to do it and that is
epitomized by the other side case but
also in large part by the main character
himself or at least it should be until
the very end where he gets randomly
knocked out of a window and sent flying
to what should be his death and then all
of a sudden oh look at that turns out I
can't fly and I do have super-strength
oh what a fun coincidence so basically
every lesson and every moral and every
major theme that the movie had been
building up to get to the very end
completely falls apart so that we can
have a generic action sequence of this
kid in bad CGI just flying around and
punching bad guys because yeah that's
what we needed we just had this extended
sequence of this really cool and
admittedly some contrived and some just
humorously so ways in which the other
characters useless powers get put to use
and it's it's cool and it's fun and it's
funny and it's endearing and then the
one guy who has no powers it's like the
whole thing is but about him coming to
grips with the fact that he has our
powers suddenly as powers like and it's
not even like a like I'm be careful what
you what you wish for you know learn to
value what you what you have thing he
just suddenly has the thing that he
never had that his entire art was
learning how to deal with the fact they
didn't have it now he has it hmm I know
that they're trying to frame it like a
reward that like he had his art and now
he can have his powers except it doesn't
work it just completely falls apart
especially the circumstances under which
he happens he doesn't earn them he just
gets damn freakin lucky that they showed
up at the moment that they did and it's
stupid I know it takes what could have
been like a fun light
harmless enjoyable little film it just
completely blows it in the ending but
that's probably really unfair but I had
to [ __ ] about it anyway and that's the
reason why I think sky high is a good
movie with a bad ending well I got that
off my chest how much you wanna bet
nobody watches this does anyone care
about this movie I don't know I'll find
out how much you want to bet I get
completely dogpile Don by a secret cabal
of massive sky-high fans that I didn't
know existed it's the Internet
anything's possible in any case what are
your thoughts whatever they are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it also there's a whole bunch
of buttons and links including one to my
patreon if you feel like checking it out
if you don't don't sweat it though
because at the end of the day folks you
are the council I just run the meetings
and until next time this council is
adjourned why did I do that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]